we are constantly being bombarded with
information what to do what to think
what to Value before we can make
effective decisions in our work life in
our personal life and our work
relationships and our personal
relationships we have to take the time
to think about what is it that we truly
value what is it that we prioritize
today we'll look at how best to do this
my name is Matt Abrahams and I teach
strategic communication at Stanford
Graduate School of Business welcome to
think fast talk smart the podcast
today I am happy to be joined by
Charlotte Burgess Auburn Charlotte
teaches classes at Stanford's hasso
platner Institute of Design also known
as the d-school where she serves as the
Director of community Charlotte recently
published a d-school guide called you
need a Manifesto how to craft your
convictions and put them to work it's
super exciting to have you here today
Charlotte welcome thanks for being here
thanks so much I'm really excited to be
here great let's get started before we
dive into crafting Creeds and making
manifestos I was struck by a line in
your bio that said you see yourself as
an extroverted introvert I believe a lot
of our listeners see themselves the same
way I'd love to have you elaborate on
what being an extroverted introvert
means for you and how it shows up in
your work and personal life
I think of myself as an introvert
because I I really identify with the
definition of an introvert as somebody
who really needs to
go be by themselves in order to recharge
right so that in the presence of people
they're sort of using energy but in
order to regain energy they need to go
away from people and be quiet and that
describes me to a t but when I am with
people I'm very energetic and outgoing
I'm excited to be with them I just can't
do it for a very very long period of
time without exhausting myself
I cherish my time alone to reflect and
recharge as well as loving you know to
be the center of a party all right and I
think a lot of people feel that way I
sit on the high extreme of extroversion
so to to hear that sounds a little
foreign to me but I can absolutely see
how many people like yourself and our
listeners might feel that way let's get
into manifestos what are they who are
they for and and how do they help us in
different areas of Our Lives
so a Manifesto is a statement of purpose
and a script for Action my take on a
Manifesto is kind of a more modern and
personal one I think that rather than
recruiting others what we really need to
do these days is to recruit ourselves we
are currently in the middle of a
Maelstrom of being recruited by everyone
at every moment I mean anybody with a
telephone in their pocket is constantly
being recruited their attention is being
being drawn and I think we need to spend
some time to recruit ourselves to our
own cause and a personal Manifesto is a
a compass a navigation tool to help you
find your way through what at the moment
feels like a pretty hazardous navigation
scheme
um through life
I think it's so powerful to allow
ourselves time to just think about
what's important to us and and to give
ourselves some direction be it if we're
starting out in our careers or perhaps
pivoting or making choices so I like
this idea of recruiting yourself yeah I
mean if you're not living life according
to your own values your your most likely
living them according to someone else's
so really giving yourself the time to
explore that I think is pretty critical
I'd like to talk more about values in
your book you talk about how values
serve as the essential first ingredients
for our manifestos how can we identify
and prioritize our values so values are
really
um I I had a hard time with this at
first I really thought like how do I
figure out what it is that I value
you know it feels intimidating somehow
that you need to get like get to some
deep standard of your being the more I
read about it the more I understood that
values are literally that they are what
you value in your life and some of them
can be deeply held and really immovable
for you and then others are kind of like
what do you value today right like I
value my latte today
but getting to your values right is a is
a process it is not something that like
it doesn't like come to you out of the
blue you're not awakened to it in some
amazing way and it can be really easy I
do a a little exercise with with
students that I I put into the book
which is I ask people to think about
things that they love doing to create a
little thought experiment that where
they write down some really nicely like
flowery language detailed flower
language about something that they love
to do and then to pick apart that
language to find the types of activities
that they get excited about and why they
get excited about them so I have them
use a special format which is like I
love to do this because of this and
anything that comes after the word
because has a verb in it and if you go
looking for that verb that verb is going
to suggest something about what it is
that you value so it's it's really just
about
digging in your own understanding making
it easy for yourself to identify things
which then you can spend time with right
you can identify these first versions of
it using these kinds of exercises then
you can interrogate that you can say do
I we value that why do I value that yeah
so what I I hear you say several things
there one is we don't have to put these
values on this pedestal that they can be
they can be minor they can be major and
that there's some pretty simple ways
that we can go to identify our values I
enjoy doing this because as a simple way
and then we can look in interrogate and
prioritize and and look at which are
more or less important which sounds much
easier than when I first read your book
and thought oh my goodness I have to
think about what are my core values once
you have these values identified how do
we go about creating our Manifesto can
you walk us through your 5c process that
you talk about yeah these are the
elements events that you need to be
investigating and exploring you need to
commence you need to begin so you need
to be willing to begin you need to do
something some some work to consider the
place you find yourself in your context
your your bias your your goals and your
values and you just spend a little time
working on those things to to understand
them and to describe them so the core
what I ask people to do to create a
first Manifesto is to find sources of
inspiration that they can use as raw
material to create their own Manifesto
out of so go find someone else's
Manifesto pull it apart and put it back
together as your own as a way to to
begin right it is not the last Manifesto
that you should make it is the first one
you should make because it's the easiest
one to do right and as soon as you get
the first one done you're on the road to
really developing a sense of how you
want to use that navigational tool and
it it sounds to me like your process is
really about two things giving yourself
permission to start and to recognize
that a Manifesto is a living document it
changes it evolves and it strikes me
that and correct me if I'm wrong it's
less about the product of the manifesto
itself but it's much more about the
process that's important do I have that
right yeah I mean I think it is much
more about the process and yet the
product is the thing that then allows
you to engage into the process right if
you keep your values and your beliefs
inside and in your head and don't get
them out of your head and out onto paper
you can't really
have a great conversation with them I
think being able to manifest things
outside of yourself allows you to to see
them from a slightly different
perspective and and to engage with them
in ways that are very intentional and
deliberate and that's all you really
need to be able to do is to engage with
your values and beliefs in intentional
and deliberate ways that then allow you
to create
shortcuts for yourself so that when you
are confronted with a moment of
difficulty or a place where you need to
make a decision that might be difficult
you have something to lean on yeah I'm
seeing a lot of parallels between this
preparation of a Manifesto that you're
talking about two things that we've
talked a lot about before on this
podcast in terms of communication
preparing yourself if you're preparing a
presentation or for a q a session you
would spend some time thinking about
what are the important things I want to
cover and how do I want to structure it
and where are my values around these
certain issues and it sounds like a
Manifesto essentially does that not for
presentation but for our lives it helps
give us something to refer to I find
that very intriguing it allows us to use
some skills that we use for other
circumstances and apply them to
ourselves do you have specific advice
for people on how to actually share
their manifestos to communicate it is it
is it let me share my Manifesto or these
these three ideas or is it is it
developing stories that you tell over
and over again that reflect what's
important to you how do you best
communicate your Manifesto one of the
things that I talk about in the book is
that you know form and style matter
right the the old Marshall mcluhan quote
the medium is the message is very much
at play here it really does matter the
way that you decide to present it and
the both the format that you use and the
form that it takes
um but it
people should choose a format and a form
that speaks to them where they're where
they need to see it in the manifesto
project that I run the easiest method to
create a first Manifesto is to collage
right and so that's what I have people
do I have them use scissors and glue
sticks and I have manifestos printed out
and they cut out the pieces that they
want and they collage it all together in
ways are interesting to them as a first
draft right this is their very first
draft and then the next thing I ask them
to do is to really think about
where do you want this to show up in
your life what are the moments that are
sticky for you like where where are the
moments where you either take time to
reflect or where you most need something
to be staring you in the face to talk to
you about your values it's like is it
your your phone background is it your
Zoom background do you want it to be a
communication tool to help introduce
yourself to other people so that you can
begin your relationships with other
people in a very transparent and
authentic way like that may be the zoom
background version which is like ask me
about my Manifesto right you know and
some people may be like I don't really
want to talk to people about my
Manifesto but I need to have it when I'm
in conflict with myself or in conflict
with others or I'm I'm feeling at a
Crossroads in some way and maybe that's
something that it's in a little I had a
former
um boss of mine who had uh who had it in
a on a card a laminated card in his
wallet had just had like one sentence
that was his kind of thing and whenever
he needed it he would just like pull it
out of his wallet
I always love talking to people from the
d-school because it's all about glue
sticks and Post-it notes
and I I think that's fun and I think it
it points to that there can be a a a
very tactile and playful nature to some
very serious yeah
you know play is critical I think in
this case as well the thing that I think
it really does for me and for the
students that I'm working with here is
that it really eliminates that
intimidation Factor because when you're
playing the result is something that
might be marvelous but it doesn't count
in some way it doesn't count against you
and I think that piece is like terrific
it's like everyone wins so we we started
talking about how you make it
approachable by by devaluing if you'll
allow me the the importance of values
right so it's more approachable but also
in the way you actually physically
construct it is also playful and and
both of those make it more approachable
what I'm taking away from your comments
about communication are each of us will
create our own need and ways of
communicating our Manifesto there's no
one right way some of us will want to
broadcast it and others of us might want
to keep it very private and personal but
part of it strikes me I think of
creating a Manifesto is to think about
how do I want to share it Beyond Myself
and and I I think that in and of itself
is a valuable uh thought process
well I've thoroughly enjoyed our
conversation before we end I'd like to
ask you the same three questions I ask
everyone who joins me are you up for
that I am absolutely all right
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you have ever
received in a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would it
be okay so mine is
um
it's not about you
which is advice that I got from the
wonderful Jillian Grodsky who was
psychologist who worked with us in the
early days of the D school and really
helped me to understand that when I am
communicating with other human beings
which is pretty much what I do right
most of the time when they're talking to
me about things that may sound like
they're about me or about my work or
about my project or about the d-school
what they're really talking about is
what matters to them right when I'm
listening to people I need to be
listening for not what's wrong with me
or what's right with me but what's with
them right where are the these people
coming from and the the ways in which I
can communicate with them best will
respond to the things that they care
about
so it's really reminding yourself to be
focused on the audience the other person
and to take that perspective it's about
empathy and we've talked a lot about
that on this podcast let me ask you a
question two who is a communicator that
you admire and why
one of the people that I'm most who's
communication skill I admire
so much is Sarah Stein Greenberg who's
the executive director of the d-school
and she is one of those people who can
choose their words incredibly
beautifully just feel like when she
talks about stuff I I just I'm like wow
that is amazing and I think the reason
why I admire it so much is because it's
so different from my own communication
style which is much more a gut you know
uh laying it all out there and and also
like terribly circuitous right and so
communicators like that who are these
incredibly cogent and clear setting up
your your arguments and knocking them
down are the folks who I really admire
mostly because they're different from
myself I've gotten to know Sarah over
over the last year or so and she was a
guest on this show and her book is
fantastic as well and I agree she is
very articulate and she's very good at
connecting with people she speaks to and
those are skills that I hear you at
admiring in others as well as do I
our final question question three what
are the first three ingredients that go
into a successful communication recipe
from your perspective I I thought about
these for a minute
and here they are
Humanity
humility
and hustle
those listening in know I love things
that come in three and I love
alliteration so walk us through the
three H's give us a little more detail I
mean I think humanity is definitely very
easy to see that communication methods
that don't include Humanity are a
failure from the very beginning it's
just important to no matter how who or
what you're trying to communicate that
you take into account the humanity of
your audience and of yourself and I
think the more that we do that the
better we are at at connecting across
Gulfs right
ability is a similar kind of thing it's
just to not assume that you have all the
answers or even that everyone else has
all the answers right to to really be
able to be open to change and to be open
to to being taught to learning and over
time and to be okay with not being
perfect right like
um
I I just I feel like one of the another
piece of good communication advice that
I was given by Julian was to stop
repairing the things I'm trying to say
while I'm trying to listen to other
people and that's just that's humility
is to put yourself in a posture of
learning and a posture of listening
and I think that one's key and hostile
is just like
try to get out there on time don't don't
sit on things don't wait to to
communicate with people don't wait for
them to communicate with you reach out
and and get out there and do it it
always gets better if you if you do
something right like yeah I really
really like the humanity the humility
and the hustle to me it's about be
empathetic that's that's all about
Humanity it's about being open and
that's what humility is about and then
it's it's about taking initiative and I
clearly see those as incredibly
important ingredients
thank you so much Charlotte you've
helped us understand the importance of a
Manifesto and finding our values and
thinking about communicating it and I
wish you the best of luck on your book
you need a Manifesto thank you thank you
so much I'm so glad to have been here
[Applause]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn
thank you